[Música]
todos
quien ha tenido un reto en la vida
hace 8 años un compañero de clases
me encerró en contra de mi voluntad en
un salón de fotografía mi universidad
me arranco mi camisa a la fuerza
me manos yo sin mi consentimiento
me acorraló
y yo me sentí la persona más impotente y
más diminuta y más débil
de la faz sobre la tierra
me costó más de un año hablar
me sentía amenazada me sentí vulnerada
yo la verdad siempre había querido
entrar a esa universidad estudiar artes
y cuando eso me pasó
mi sueño se fue al piso me sentí rota
y lo más difícil para mí fue contarle a
mi familia
sentí una tristeza y un miedo tan grande
que se convirtió en una depresión y
pensé que no iba a salir de esa incluso
considere quitarme la vida
hasta que un día decidí romper el
silencio porque me di cuenta que este
abuso sexual se estaba repitiendo en más
personas de mi universidad
y que la libertad y la justicia
realmente está en hablar y contar tu
verdad
sanar empezó por confiar en mí
en volver a confiar en todas las
personas que me rodean
y para mí el arte fue mi refugio
la pintura y mi piano fueron mi escape
a través de esos colores puede volver a
encontrar a mi niña interior y puedo
volver a expresarme otra vez
y me di cuenta que los retos en la vida
te definen qué camino tienes que tomar
me di cuenta que al dolor lo podemos
transformar en una oportunidad de
liberar nuestro potencial
y lo más importante
me di cuenta
que lo que te define no es lo que te
pasó lo que realmente te define es cómo
te levantaste después de haberte caído
yo antes andaba por mi vida ciega
ocupándome de mis asuntos y nunca me
había percatado cuan importante son
todas las personas que te rodean cuán
importante es tu país cuán importante es
la humanidad
que esto no me estaba pasando solo a mí
la violencia sexual es una epidemia
mundial en nuestro país cada 22 minutos
un menor de edad es abusado sexualmente
estas cifras son del año pasado en
medicina legal y yo te pregunto si eso
es le está sucediendo a nuestros niños y
nuestras niñas colombianas qué le está
sucediendo a toda colombia
el año pasado
el centro de memoria y conflicto el
observatorio reveló que hubo 15.687
víctimas de violencia sexual en el marco
del conflicto armado colombiano
y yo te digo una cosa para un actor de
conflicto armado es más fácil revelar
que cometió un asesinato a revelar que
cometió un acto de violencia sexual
yo te pregunto y te invito
a revisar si estas cifras eran exactas
si a mí me tomo más de un año en hablar
me costó tanto trabajo
y también tengamos en cuenta que hay
gente que incluso se suicida después de
un abuso sexual
realmente serán estas cifras exactas
o tal vez la magnitud del problema sea
tan grande que no lo alcanzamos a medir
y por eso yo decidí dedicar mi vida a
servir a mi país
decir que yo no me iba a sanar
únicamente yo sino que a través de esas
herramientas que encontré durante mi
proceso de sanación iba también a
transmitirse las a otras personas y
enseñarles cómo tan a sanar también
porque todos tenemos la capacidad de
auto transformarnos
y por eso decidí
recopilarlas en cuatro etapas que son
cuatro pasos claves y hoy te nos quiero
compartir porque todos los seres humanos
tenemos pruebas en la vida el primero es
la catarsis el segundo es el cierre de
herida el tercero
es el perdón y el cuarto es encontrar tu
y keegan la catarsis es una apertura de
vida sanadora es como un vómito
liberador
que saca todo tu dolor todo lo que te
carcome por dentro todo lo que está
escondiendo inconsciente esa información
hay que sacarla a la memoria racional
porque solamente cuando eres consciente
del problema puedes solucionarlo y
transformarlo y empezarlo a moldear como
si fuera una plastilina
hasta que quede como se te dé la gana
y cuando nosotros abrimos la herida hay
que cerrarla porque no puedes andar por
la vida y con la vía abierta como si
fuera una llaga sales a la calle le
entra la tierra se infecta lo mismo
sucede con las heridas del alma
y cómo hacemos para cerrarla conectando
con tu esencia cuál es la esencia del
ser humano es tu niño interior
ese niño de cuando tenías de 2 a 8 años
es el que esconde tus sueños
es tu motor en la vida es el que tiene
las respuestas a tus preguntas es el
maestro y cuando tú vuelves a abrazar a
ese niño interior recuperas tu norte a
ese niño hay que empoderar lo hay que
amarlo y sobre todo hay que perdonarlo
porque si tú no te perdonas a ti mismo
es imposible perdonar a la otra persona
por ejemplo cuando a mí me pasó esto del
abuso sexual yo me la pasaba echándome
la culpa
pero porque tuve que estar en ese salón
de fotografía preciso ese día pero
porque me quedé callada tanto tiempo y
me echaba toda la rabia finalmente quien
estaba atentando contra sí misma yo o
sea yo en este momento no tengo ni idea
en dónde está esta persona que me atacó
ese día que estaba pasando por su cabeza
no tengo ni idea ni es mi problema
mi asunto es mi vida y si yo me perdono
yo puedo perdonar a la otra persona
y en el caso puntual de un abuso sexual
el atacante puede ser un hombre o puede
ser una mujer
y también se puede trabajar un proceso
simbólico del perdón
por ejemplo si esa persona si el
atacante fue un hombre
ese hombre esa figura masculina puede
entregarle un objeto que simboliza el
perdón a esa persona que está en proceso
de sanación y cuando esa persona lo
recibe
y abraza a esa persona que tiene al
frente esa figura masculina está
representando no solo a su atacante sino
a todos los hombres que conocen su vida
y lo mismo cuando es una mujer abraza
perdona y se libera
el perdón es soltar
el perdón es recordar sin dolor
el perdón es honrar tu pasado
y cuando tú hiciste catarsis y logras de
cerrar esa herida y lograste perdonar de
corazón es mucho más sencillo encontrar
tu hígado
el liquigás es un término japonés que
significa tu razón de ser
cuál es tu propósito en la vida
para que viniste a este mundo
para qué estás acá en esta tierra
todo eso se puede encontrar hay una
herramienta muy poderosa que se conoce
como el mapa de sueños o el sueño grafo
lo importante de esta herramienta no
solamente es identificar cuáles son tus
sueños cuáles son tus metas sino de
dónde vienen
porque haces lo que haces para que eres
bueno que estás haciendo con todos tus
dones tus habilidades
qué te apasiona
los estás utilizando para compartir para
aprender
para servirle a tu país o los estás
escondiendo y te los vas a llevar a tu
tumba
de eso se trata de esta herramienta
y todo eso construye tu hígado y
hablando de dones de pasiones a mí me
encanta la música
y yo amo la música desde chiquita me
apasiona y durante mi proceso de
sanación
compuse una canción que se llama
despegar
esta canción te la va a cantar hoy
porque la música conecta corazones
ayer fuimos en silencio nos callamos por
el miedo
el perro nos dejó ciego y no vimos lo
que nos pasó
los voceros que te comió está solo en su
demencia nosotros somos una sola vos
como tormenta
hoy no invierno salida lo que nos tocó
desaparece desaparecerá siente a tu
corazón escucha el sonido de tu voz
así
y ese silencio abismal con el grito
arranca
tu violador no te vas frenas despegas
despedidas
el miedo despegará
es imposible invisibilizar la impunidad
nuestra memoria grita grita en honor a
tu verdad es imposible invisibilizar la
impunidad nuestra memoria grita grita en
honor a tu verdad
invierno salida lo que nos tocó sin
permiso desaparecerá siempre a tu
corazón escucha el sonido de tu voz
y este silencio abismal con el grito
arrancar a tu violador no te va a frenar
despegas despegar las del miedo
[Música]
a
hola
con las mías
salas
s
el miedo despegará
ah
muchas gracias
[Música]
i